gr
fin mars le tempo fest de chibougamau
est en cours le printemps à la porte
d'entrée de la baie james
l'hiver n'en finit plus tueur manon cyr
originaire de montmagny est arrivé dans
la région à l'âge de 25 ans comme
fonctionnaire elle est depuis 2009 mais
reste de la bible
sachons gamme on la voit partout comme
ici au centre communautaire ou à la
salle de spectacle avec des femmes
autochtones et dossiers ne manquent pas
même pour une ville de 7 mille six cents
habitants
après un ralentissement de plusieurs
années certains pensent qu un boom
économique est pour bientôt
on aime penser qu'on fait la bonne
affaire de se préparer et le jour où ça
va arriver on sera prêt
chibougamau a toujours vécu des mines et
de la forêt depuis ses débuts dans les
années 30 la rue principale et servait
de piste d'atterrissage
la route est arrivé vingt ans plus tard
à son apogée la région était la capitale
du cuivre de l'est du canada
on y trouvait aussi de l'or
chibougamau dans les années 80 vous avez
12000 la population à 86 la base
militaire fermée et vous avez commencé à
avoir une décroissance au niveau du
développement
aujourd'hui chibougamau ne manque pas de
tous les emplois de 100 mille dollars
par année dans les mines et tous les
services d'une grande ville et la nature
à proximité
on trouve ici une station de ski où
monchal coup il est long l'hiver ici
début avril il faisait moins 27 le
concessionnaire ski-doo ne manque pas de
clients cette année seulement il a vendu
200 brouage
ici il y a dû faire et aussi une grande
variété de minerais or diamant lithium
vanadium une mine vient d'ouvrir et une
autre est en construction et il y à
d'autres projets la mairesse vient de
conclure une entente avec stone loué le
future mine de diamants située à une
heure de vol pour que les travailleurs
soient d'abord recruté achi mondiale et
pour que les autres travailleurs vient
aussi prendre la navette aérienne à
chibougamau
lorsqu'on dit si on s'installe dans nos
communautés
la chance qu'il a ce final à votre
entreprise sont meilleurs et nous ça le
vrai but depuis le ralentissement de
fermont la capitale n'aurait pas dû
faire
on prévoit une migration de travailleurs
vers chibougamau
des lots qui ont beaucoup d'expérience
une mine qui ouvre ses du travail pour
vingt ans j'ai sauté sur l'occasion pour
embarquer avec la nouvelle équipe puis
de relever ce nouveau défi
en espérant aussi pour moi
personnellement et mes collègues de
travail que le diamant vont être plus
fiable que l'aluminé redfin plusieurs
maisons sont en construction de nouveaux
quartiers apparaissent ici c'est le
nouveau secteur qu'on appelle le
quartier ouest une planification de 150
terrains il ya 48 terrain pour lesquels
les services mise pour son rendu puisque
c'est érection prêt avant l'avenir c'est
aussi le secteur forestier
chantiers chibougamau est le plus gros
employeur local avec 600 travailleurs
le quart de la population active
l'entreprise transforme chaque année 8
millions d'arbres surtout de l'épinette
noire
elle compte à son actif de nombreuses
réalisations dont ce pont dans la
communauté voisine de mistissini et le
tout nouveau stade de soccer du quartier
saint michel à montréal
elle tente aussi de s'implanter dans le
marché nord américain
chibougamau on encourage l'industrie
locale
c'est pas nécessairement plus cher il
faut juste les prendre avant et au début
des travaux dit tu veux faire en
structure de mort pour être capable d'
adapter ton prochain conséquence
d'autres immeubles de la ville sont
aussi en bois dont le tout nouveau
centre de formation pour réussir ses
projets il faut placer ses efforts au
bon endroit
c'est ce que manon avait commencé dès le
début de son mandat en 2009 c'est qu'il
y avait d'un interminable litige et
aucune instance décisionnelle pour les
résoudre
la pérennité de l'activité la région
ensemble ils ont conçu une forme de
gouvernement régional égalitaire
autochtones et non autochtones
le seul au canada une première mondiale
il a été officiellement créé par le
gouvernement du québec en 2013
il couvre le plus vaste territoire
municipal du monde
près de 300 mille kilomètres carrés pour
une population d'à peine deux mille
personnes le complexe hydroélectrique lg
de robert bourassa s'y trouvent
c'est tout le territoire de la baie
james à l'exception des ve et les
villages qui rit et non autochtone ce
gouvernement régional s'appelle et
yoichi baie james
les questions de développement et
d'environnement ils sont discutés manon
cyr en est la présidente avant son
parler que d'eux les tiges qu'en parler
des municipalités s'étaient toujours
négatif c'est la première fois qu'ils se
met face à face tonnes forum tous les
chefs crie pas juste les deux ou trois
chefs et d'entendre les chefs qui ont
jamais parlé avec les mains au mspb
sortir de la réunion
puis il parlait de de leur président
notre présidente est vraiment bonne et
efficace les usagers format le 49e
degrés soit la latitude à laquelle se
trouve notre ville non si on n'est pas à
court d'idées pour promouvoir
chibougamau elle vient de lancer une
campagne d'image pour mettre sa ville
sur la carte
souvent les gens savent même pas ce que
c'est chez google souvent ils vont
penser de moi que ça existe comme non
mais est ce que ça existe la malcombe il
est aussi l'hôte et les manger souvent
un bon ils pensent qu'on est de sa
quote-part donc c'est vraiment probant
un touriste allemand stratégie
elle veut en faire rien de moins que la
capitale de la nordicité est rappelé que
son nom veut dire lieu de rencontre